we heard the warnings I tried to
convince people to slow down slow down
AI I tried for years but we didn't now
we live in a world controlled by
artificial intelligence how did we let
this happen will we be able to survive
and is this the end of the world this is
what if and here's what would happen if
we created a super intelligence the days
with AI like Siri and Alexa that made
our lives better are now over we no
longer control AI in fact if it wants to
it can control us with a super
intelligence being created there's no
telling what it would do one thing we do
know is that this AI would be far
smarter than any human being it would
quickly create new technologies that
humans today could never even dream of
but wait how exactly did we get here the
very first digital computer was invented
in 1937 as a way to help humanity and
for the most part computers and AI have
given us a lot of good in addition to
giving us smartphones the internet and
video game consoles it also allowed us
to explore the galaxy make new medicines
and even robots human intelligence led
to the birth of technology but as we
continue to improve artificial
intelligence AI may become smart enough
to start running itself technology will
become so advanced that it won't need
humans to operate it anymore
becoming uncontrollable as AI becomes
free to do whatever it pleases it will
continue to improve on itself becoming
more advanced with every passing second
this is known as a technological
singularity this technological
singularity may allow AI to do almost
anything even physically such as robots
taking over our manufacturing machines
when that happens they can create their
own machines and let's be honest by the
time something like this happens humans
will most likely have created an AI that
can make its own physical objects if
something like this happens it would
pretty much only mean bad things for us
humans unfortunately this is more of a
when F than a what ever since the 1980s
thought leaders in the AI and technology
have been predicting that it could
happen some think it could even happen
by the middle of this century if it did
happen what would it mean for us as
human beings
well that would really be up to our AI
overlords in this world humans would
essentially be useless bags of meat
taking up space insulting I know but if
AI took control of everything we really
wouldn't be that useful anything that
the AI wanted to do or accomplish would
be slower and less efficient if done by
humans but if the AI were somehow to
allow us to live among them then what
would happen
well let's hope they wouldn't pave over
our crops to build more robot factories
since AI doesn't need food they most
likely wouldn't care about our feeble
human needs and what do you must do with
these things oh man what what didn't
they do they bounced them unless they
allowed us to continue to manufacture
and grow our own food it would deplete
over time leaving us humans with nothing
the only reason AI would keep us humans
alive is if they somehow liked us enough
to keep us as what would essentially be
pets we could spend time with them keep
them company maybe even cuddle with them
just like our pets do for us a life like
this wouldn't it be so bad hanging out
at home all day being well-fed not
really having a care in the world
yeah that would probably be the best bet
for Humanity because there's virtually
no chance of us overruling a
superintelligence in our current state
one way we could actually compete with
this AI as if we fused our bodies with
technology and became cyborgs allowing
the human race a different kind of
evolution one that includes artificial
intelligence but could we really do that
that sounds like a story for another
what-if
[Music]